is uh everything okay santiago
no i lost my ring did you see where it
went actually
it's behind one of these three doors why
don't you pick one
are you trying to monty hall me it's
unbelievable
i don't need monty hall ruining my place
of work but monty hall has already
ruined my home life come on sir
the math thing isn't the problem night
shift's keeping you and kevin apart you
two just need a bone
what did you say don't say it again i
said you two need a bone
wow dare you detective
diaz i am your superior officer
bone what happens in my bedroom
detective is
none of your business
don't ever speak to me like that again
why did you do that dude just pen up now
he knows problem solved
you wanted to see me i told kevin about
how i approved of your strategy for
breaking up with marcus and he said that
we were quote
sociopaths unquote so you're going to
leave him no
i think he may have a point you might
need to do more than simply
text a long drawn-out breakup is just
gonna end in a big scene and mark is
crying
he has so many emotions
[Music]
it's just so beautiful how much they
love each other
it's a commercial for a refrigerator
yes it is daunting but i did some
research on amicable
breakups i visited
www.ladiesgoodhealthmag.com backslash
sex hyphen relationships backslash eight
six seven
five nine nine nine zero four backslash
nine four three two ampersand two zero
dot html
do you know that site yeah well
apparently it is less painful
if you acknowledge the dumpy's
feelings ew but don't worry we'll
practice
i'll be marcus go
marcus i think we should break up that
makes me feel sad
i'm sad your sadness is noted i feel
acknowledged
thank you for breaking up with me it
will take me eight minutes to collect my
things
i think that went very well thank you
for coming diaz
i want to apologize for yesterday
inserting myself into my employee's
breakup with my nephew somehow uh
backfired scenario i'm the one that made
us seem like a dumb crying baby
i'm considering having my tear ducts
melted shut it's not the
end of the world to feel
things i guess not it's up there
the thing is i really cared about marcus
but he wanted to get married
and i'm just not ready for that and if
i'm not ready with a guy as great as
marcus
then what if i'm never ready
what if that was it my one chance i love
and what if i never get a second chance
i don't know
i'm just i'm just sad
well i i understand
it must be very difficult
wait are you crying yes
thank you for acknowledging my feelings
thank you for acknowledging mine
we're both great at this
[Music]
is this seat taken you really gonna do
this diaz my name is rachel weinstein
i'm a graduate student on sabbatical
study birds at the university of buenos
aires
you know cornell has a far better
ornithology department and
it's right here in new york cornell has
accused me of robbing a bank and is
going to send me to jail for 15 years
i guess we're dropping the metaphor i
don't know why you're here you're not
going to change my mind
i know i just wanted to say goodbye okay
goodbye
i hope you know your family's gonna miss
you i don't care i barely speak to them
i was talking about the nine-nine be
safe rachel weinstein
[Music]
i'm here sorry traffic was a nightmare
coming back from philadelphia
cheese steak restaurant they do
breakfast it checks out
okay
so what happened i guess i wasn't ready
to say goodbye to my family
good neither were we
now what i'm picking up on is just a
genuine moment of friendship
and respect and now i'm feeling like
you wish i would stop analyzing you
because i'm ruining the moment
but you guys are so cute and i love you
all right okay
so how's prison nobody likes cops in
here so i had to earn their respect by
starting a bunch of riots i got thrown
solitary for a week what's going on with
your face
i hate seeing you like this so i'm
flexing my eyes real hard to keep from
crying
it's okay we can still have a normal
conversation
so how's the food pay no attention to
him rosa he's very emotional
rosa why are you saying my first name
well rosa i read an article in the
medical journal that said one
destabilizing aspect of the
incarceration is the constant
dehumanization
rosa you need to be reminded that you're
more than just a number
rosa you are rosa yep that fixes prison
is there anything we can do to help you
anything you need done on the outside
no i'm good it's not a problem rosa
we're here for you rosa
whatever you need rosa
okay i'll come up with a list
[Music]
yes you should be very proud of yourself
i know things aren't exactly where you
want to be right now
but uh i promise you they will improve
thank you captain
every time someone steps up and says who
they are the world becomes a
better more interesting place so
thank you
now these fertility jugs are making me
sweat is it noticeable
no yes oh i thought we were gonna lie to
her because it's so upsetting to look at
just tell me what room the memorial is
in we don't have a lot of time to set up
about that yesterday before you
convinced me to hold a respectful
service i sent some instructions for how
i wanted the room to look
we may need to make some tweaks
so many balloon arches i know it all has
to go
okay everyone we have work to do
better much but to be clear the first
version was dope and you have my respect
for life
something else i figured out why you
want to win i hacked your work calendar
those calendars are public everyone on
the system has access
i acted i'm a hacker anyhow you took a
vacation 14 days ago and yet you already
want
another day off odd unless you need it
for a unique once-in-a-lifetime
occurrence perhaps
a proposal to your girlfriend jocelyn
what you've been dating for a year you
met each other's parents and you just
got your nails done
to present her with a ring
jocelyn broke up with me what i want the
day off so i can sit alone listen to
death metal and get my head right
but what about my nail polish solve
getting my nails done made me feel
better for a second
ah this is a trick to throw me off i bet
things are better than ever
and you oh you really are crying
rosa stop i give up i want you to know
i'm sorry for prying
win this thing and enjoy your day off
and if you ever want a friend to sit
with you
and silently listen to death metal just
know
i'm always here okay i'd like that
what no what are you freaks doing we're
leaving the competition some things are
more
important than a game no they're not
wait where are you going don't leave we
need you
you like it not at all you can leave by
the chance
i didn't help zeff i failed zeph this
case was never solved the words written
on the back
were thanks for nothing oh man that's
rough
i have held onto that car for 30 years
because i always wanted to remember what
it felt like to let someone down so i'd
never do it again
that card made me the cop i am today
without it i'm lost
since this seems important now i want to
be clear this is terry's thing i've just
been along for the ride rosa noted
yeah um i just wanted to thank you for
all your help yesterday i didn't do much
it was nothing good day what's going on
just very busy get back to work
wait what do you have in there
a balloon arch oh my god captain she is
magnificent
vindication welcome back captain holt
i'm really glad we could help you with
this
oh no you're not gonna just jump back in
here now that it all worked out thank
you dears
no no thank terry i did this oh i'm done
you know what i did all of this this is
all me this is ridiculous
you